có thể đánh hoặc sinh cho họ cơ sự ở khoảng bình,
cố gái em nhỏ giữ sống lực sét.
Vào khoảng 18,5 kẻ hay bối tháng mười,
các em định phương lực tâm à,
tình kèo lực sảo à,
đình được lực sảo à,
đình cần lực sảo à và đình bèo lực sảo bê.
Học sinh cho một phổ thông dật chú bố chạc,
khi đang vui đua,
lực ngờ nghe tình kêu cữ thảm tiet,
mẹ ơi, mẹ ơi,
phong lên từ vây dưới,
ngay lực tức, em định phương lực tâm à,
khiện thấy em nhỏ đang chối giữ sống lực trẻ sét,
không trước sâu giữ em định phương vực gật các bạn cùng trải theo,
sơ nhăn trong lâu xuống sối bối ra cữ người,
tương nhiên,
sống lực trẻ mạnh khi em phương không thể kịp tức cận thả em nhỏ,
nhận thấy tình nghiên khẩn cấp,
bốn bạn còn lại là đình kêu,
đình được, đình cần hư và đình bèo,
đánh nhăn trong trải xả đón chức,
cho một vị trí thuật lợi hơn để bối ra cữ người,
với sinh phối hợp nhăn nghe,
mưa chỉ vào giúp tạm,
hãy điên cân hư và điên bèo đã tiếp cận được em định gị,
học lực thái trường kỳ học xuống mô thức trải,
đưa em lên bởi anh toàn,
trong khi đó,
điên tiếp và điên kêu cũng kịp tư cữ được em định,
học lực mô thức trường kỳ học xuống mô thức trải thật khải viêm,
sâu giữ người thái em nhỏ,
thức bạn đã sận rau các em về nhà anh toàn.